hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
you may have seen some bad
newspaper articles about me you may have
seen things that look like a smear
campaign
and i want to clear that all up in this
video and i want to tell you exactly
where it all stems from because there's
been lots of different people that seem
to have written stories about me
but you know what it actually stems from
one place
so i've never done this before but i'm
going to give you the facts and the
evidence and the story
of how it all started and why i started
picking up
so much negative attention and honestly
this is going to completely shock you
but i'm going to give you the full story
with facts and evidence
so my suggestion would be to watch this
from beginning to end there is an
individual in particular a small few
people that
do everything they can to get this taken
down
so watch it from beginning to end and
share the heck out of it before youtube
ban this video little bit of context so
you know the back story 2009 i bought my
first house age
17 no money down deal i then became
pretty successful in property
became financially for age 21 was in
bible college
traveled did some charitable projects
set up a training kings christian
business network you want to know my
story go
check it out on the life of samuel leeds
now what happened was in 2015 i really
started scaling the business i started
aggressively deal packaging and selling
deals
i sold hundreds of property deals made a
lot of money
started aggressively investing that
money into property and i had also
people ask me to teach them about
property
started running events and i did put
myself out there i did put myself on the
map
and i remember a few years back now i
saw a little thread written about me
on a forum called property tribes
property tribes is owned by
nick tad but his wife vanessa warwick
she kind of
runs the show she's the face of it and
vanessa warwick was
questioning me and basically trying to
imply that i wasn't really wealthy
and she was saying look at his companies
on company's house and i'm thinking
you don't know me this is crazy like
we've never met who's this person is she
a journalist is she i don't i don't
understand
but i thought maybe i should respond
maybe i shouldn't respond
i didn't feel like i owed any answers to
anybody but i thought you know what as
i've put myself
on the map maybe i'll respond so i went
on there and i explained that the reason
that
you can't find my wealth on my companies
is because my wealth is earned in
property and i buy properties in my name
you can't see that in company's house
the reason why charity's not registered
and i explained and and and also there's
some of the deals they were saying
samuel just sells deals on right move
and it's not legitimate and it's
and i'm saying here's what i actually do
and here's how we sell deals
and i explained everything and i ended
this by saying to vanessa warwick and
everybody on the thread oh
you say come down to my office if you
want this is the office address
if you want to come down look at
everything look at the paperwork i'm all
good i got
nothing to hide now what happened was on
this thread was it began to run into
this campaign of questions and questions
steered by vanessa where they wanted to
see receipts for everything and this
and i thought you know what i didn't
sign up for this
i got nothing to hide you didn't come
down to my office but i don't really
want to be spending my time
showing receipts to strangers because
they just think they have a right to
know everything i don't i don't really
sign up for this
my wife um amanda is now pregnant and
we're going to be having a baby and i
just thought let's just have a
quiet life why do i deal with and whilst
i was successful in
property my training company at this
point wasn't making any money
it was years before my training company
started making money so
i don't need the grief from the training
company i'm making good money from
property
so me and amanda we move into a lovely
little barn conversion and we just enjoy
our profits from property still to deal
sourcing a little bit
tip some of the training over with some
of the students that have signed up but
i'm not aggressively growing it
a little bit later i thought you know
what i kind of i'm getting itchy feet
and i started
um aggressively growing my property
business again
and i was getting a massive demand of
people saying can you run some more
training and can you do this and have
you got deals and i thought forget it
i'm going to do this thing i don't care
about the hate
i don't care about this i'm just going
to do it because i want to do it
it's a mission thing so i really really
pressed hard i started packaging deals i
set up a training company
i became more successful my wealth
started increasing and what i noticed is
as my wealth started increasing
as my success started increasing this
little forum on property tribes
was getting more and more rattled and
the haters began to get more and more
um obsessed and at this point to be
honest
everybody loved me it was just property
tribes and occasionally some people say
have you seen property tribes though and
i believe
ignore them they're like it's like when
you leave a coke can at the bottom of
the garden for the wasps to fly around
you know i'm not i don't want to get in
the in the coke can i'll leave them to
talk
but the media loved me at the time and i
was getting loads of positive stories
my students were making it into the
newspaper i was running events i was
packing deals
everything was going really well now
don't get me wrong if somebody in
property tribes was a genuine customer
of mine if they'd paid me money and
they've got a concern or a gripe
i'm going to meet with them talk with
them deal with it but if it's just
someone just speculating that's never
met me that's never done any training
then to be honest i'm just going to
ignore that now there was
one lady who was part of property tribes
and she was bickering and saying how
bad i was and it really surprised me at
the time now this lady was called diane
granville now i don't normally like to
name people but
as she has publicly on tv and in the
newspapers
said a lot about me i'm gonna name her
okay so diane granville
she starts saying bad things about me on
property tribes which really surprised
me because
she came to the training and she really
liked it and she left me a video
testimonial
she then paid for further training she
left me a video testimonial
for the further advanced training and
was really happy
okay and um
um okay would you recommend do you have
anything to travel again
absolutely without them without a shadow
of a doubt
um i think the thing with samuel not the
other people out there everyone of
course they teach you have learners you
have training
but samuel is 150 genuine he wants you
to succeed
he makes sure that when you leave you
have sufficient to go out there and do
what you need to do
so now she's complaining she's seeing
this group
that are talking on property tribes and
these people are saying how bad i am and
she comes to me and says i want my money
back now we spoke to diane and we said
look
why do you it's like going to a
restaurant and eating the food
and saying it was great and then leaving
and then some weeks later coming back
and saying actually you know what
a few people have said these things and
i'm not really happy and i've heard some
bad stuff so
can i have my money back please so we
talked to her but the conclusion was
no and not only was she asking for a
money back she paid two thousand pounds
in total she spent five days with me two
days at the crash course for free
loved it three days of the deal finding
extravaganza paid two thousand pounds
and she was putting a claim in she was
saying i want two thousand
five pounds lest i take you to court she
pursues it legally
not just the 2000 pounds that she paid
for the training but also her
costs her transport petrol hotels
she wanted back and thought that we owed
her and
i i i said to her i said to him before i
went to court i said you're not owed
that money
you're not going to win this you want a
bit of a losing battle like
if you if we can put it right if we can
help you if we can what can we do but
guys this is really not gonna it's silly
but you know she did take us to court
and this is the very first time
that i'd ever been taken to court ever
and it's the very last time that i've
ever been to court ever
but i remember that one freaky time when
i was in court with one of my students
that had done the training
and had been delivered to who was trying
to get everything i remember the judge
me i had a witness with me as well who
was also on the course and diane
granville i remember thinking this is
crazy what is going to happen i'm kind
of interested to see what's going to
happen
and when she was saying what the problem
was and diane was present in her case
the judge to be honest was looking very
like
what's the problem and i was thinking i
don't think this is going to end well
for diane
and her case was thrown
out the judge saw my video testimonial
which it was now she'll probably say oh
but it was a technicality or
but it was thrown out now you might
think
oh you must have been really pleased
samuel you used to be like yes
i didn't feel that way at all actually
when when the judge threw the case out i
looked it down and i just thought
this must be one big misunderstanding
she's been skewed somehow maybe by
property tribes or
like this is really strange and i didn't
feel at peace about the situation
also diane granville had been trolling
me for months and saying oh you know i'm
going to god this
and i just thought i don't really want
this i don't want the hassle of this
i went to court out of principle because
i wasn't prepared to be like bullied
i'm gonna take you to court and i'm like
no i'll go to court i went to court
her case was thrown out but then when i
left the courtroom
i actually saw diane um
i saw her in the hallway in the corridor
and
you know she looked really sad she
looked like she'd been crying
and i felt for her i
had a sense of compassion i just thought
why is she so upset
she got to all this trouble she's paid
all these court costs
to try and get two thousand pounds plus
like
i don't understand her but she's
obviously not in a great place
and i actually approached diane after
her case had been thrown out but just
after
same day and i said look what's the
issue and we sat down and we spoke
and she said oh you didn't feed me at
the event and the chairs weren't comfy
literally and i said okay look we're
going to get
better chairs maybe we should start
feeding people
what can i do now for you what can i oh
and we had a conversation
and i said look i'll give you back your
two thousand pound i'll give you two
thousand five hundred that you
you never even paid us i'll happily do
that okay
because i felt like the pr my my point
of improving that i didn't owe the money
i said i'll happily give it to you back
but can you just
live a happy life stop trolling me
online every day on property tribes
and as long as you're prepared to sign a
confidentiality agreement just to say
that this is because i want people to
think that
i paid you because i needed to pay you
so if
you can do that go and live a happy life
i'll transfer the money back over to you
anyway she was like thank you so much
that's really you know thank you thank
you thank you
that's cool and i felt really good about
that i was like that i i just felt like
that was the
right christian thing to do as a
christian
i'd i'd won the case but now
i had compassion i'm a compassionate
capitalist i just felt like it was the
right thing so for me it was like
ah her weight was lifted i thought great
and then she messaged me she emailed me
and said you know the thread has been
removed she signed
the agreement just like she did not
speak about me again and it was and i
thought great i sent
two thousand pounds over to diane
granville plus 500 pounds for her petrol
and transport
sent it over to her and i felt pretty
good about it as well
however very shortly after that guess
what happens
the thread goes back up and diane
granville
starts saying bad things about me again
how bad i am now
i'm like i cannot believe this
she got her money back in 2018.
i'm lucky i realized what was happening
to me and i dealt with it
we were misled we were missiled
and i think that's when i really
realized that sometimes no matter how
much you give
no matter what you do there's some
people that you are just
never gonna please and sometimes you
can't even
try and reason with unreasonable people
and really i should be spending my
energy not trying to talk to diane
granville not trying to talk to vanessa
warwick and answer on the thread and
because these are unreasonable people i
don't understand i should be spending
all of my time and all of my energy on
my students
who are paying for training who are
actually implementing
people that are putting their energy
into themselves into their businesses
who are investing their resources into
winning
and i'm gonna help them win not try and
fight off these people that i'm
never ever gonna please so property
tribes continue talking about me
watching my every move vanessa warwick
is continually
watching every video and doing a
commentary on it and at the same time
i'm working with my students really
closely
i've got now winners on a wednesday
where every single week i bring someone
on who's financially free or have their
finances revolutionized through my
training and i'll interview them
and i'm just focusing all my energy on
that and at this time some people would
read some of this
this news and think oh is it bad and
then other people would steal the
winners wednesdays and would come and
see for themself and but actually
and some people liked me and some people
didn't and that was just that someone
tagged me on a linkedin post
where a guy called mike winit was trying
to expose
grant cardone now i'm a big fan of grant
cardone and i wasn't the time and i
thought
that's a little bit unfair and i could
see what he was saying about grant
cardone
and other trainers and a lot of what he
was saying was really good and i enjoyed
his material and i thought that's really
good
but i thought it was a little bit unfair
in what he was saying about some other
trainers
and i actually approached him i messaged
him on linkedin i said
mike i'd love to interview you on my
show to talk about training courses and
standards i'd love to get your input
could we do an interview now mike
declined because he said that he was too
busy
but then shortly after he said actually
yeah let's meet up
so we ended up meeting up and i don't
know how this happened but i ended up
going on
his channel even though initially i
wanted him to come on my channel but you
know what i didn't really see the
difference because i thought me on his
channel
or whatever as long as we get to chat
and as long as it's filmed no big deal
now maybe at the time i was a little bit
naive because i didn't quite realize how
this sort of thing works and how people
edit stuff
and after going on mike's channel we
actually had a really good chat i really
enjoyed it
i quite liked him i loved the fact that
he was challenging things
with a really healthy conversation great
conversation
and i left thinking really enjoyed that
took a selfie with him
and went back in the interview we spoke
quite a lot about his property journey
as well
because i asked him what's he doing and
how he made his money and he talked to
me and
explained how he'd made money in
property and he talked through the
figures and i thought that's great
because
that shows that not only am i making
money in property but what i'm actually
teaching is valid because even mike
winner is doing
exactly what i'm teaching that's kind of
cool i'm really excited for this
interview to go out
i then had a few suspicious thoughts and
thought i wonder whether he's going to
edit this interview in such a way to try
and fit his agenda
and i messaged him and we talked back
and forth and i was like look mike
please can you send me the footage
because i want the raw footage
in case you edit it you've got it could
you please send it to me
and mike really did not want to send me
the footage and i said
look send it to me i will not publish it
until you've released yours i just want
it for peace of mind
and he would not give me the footage
when he released his
video some months later he had
edited it now i don't want to give mike
too much of a hard time because i don't
think he's a really bad guy i'd still
like mike win it but he did edit it
quite cleverly he took out the bits
where he said about how much he's making
in property and how he's made his money
he also edited a few bits in my opinion
i think it was deliberate but maybe it
wasn't he said he wasn't deliberate
but for example i said that i'd only met
grant cardone once
in london and then he had me saying that
with footage b-roll footage so i'm
saying i only met grant cardone once in
london he then has footage of me with
grant cardone in miami
and everyone's commenting going liar
liar simon said he only met grant
cardone in london once and here he is in
miami with him and everyone's commented
saying
i'm a liar but the footage of me in
miami with grant cardone was taken after
me and mike met
when i said it was true but what mike
did maybe accidentally i'll give him the
benefit of doubt was he took the footage
and he put it in and it
very much made me look like i was lying
when i wasn't so everyone's saying in
the comments samuel's a liar saying was
a lie
i told mike straight away i said look
mark you edited this you made me look
like a lie you took out the property
[ __ ] this is why i wanted the raw
footage can you please address it and
can you please tell people that i wasn't
lying
i'd still love to interview mike on my
channel i have asked him if he would
like to come on at times he's agreed and
he's got actually i don't want to
i've tried to make it really easy i said
you bring your own cameras we can do it
your way but i just want to get you on
my channel and the only reason is
because i want to talk to him about his
property journey
because when i met with him he told me
how much money he'd made he told me
about his deals and then it made me
comfortable just like okay well i paid
for his life
but then he cut his bit out and i
thought it was really interesting i'd
love
people to know about his journey and i
think the reason he probably hides it
and doesn't talk about it is because it
doesn't fit his story
because his story is oh no all these
entrepreneurs and they all say they're
making money but actually when he tells
his true story it's
he's done it he's made money people that
watched the interview and said
samuel was lying because he said he only
met grant cardone once and here's a
picture of him a second time
do people really think that or do you
think i don't know whether sometimes
people just find what they
look for because i get a lot of people
say i lied over something
like literally as silly as this you said
that you were 27 years old but you're 29
i'm like
but the video was taken two years ago
are you are you
are you really serious in the same exact
way i've had many people
that have done exposed videos on me
where they've said look samuel promises
that he will give you hand-holding
one-on-one mentoring this that and the
other
on this video from two or three years
ago
i work one-on-one with each person and
we put together a custom
tailored bespoke plan for that
individual but then say but this person
didn't get that they did that i'm like
uh no because they registered
two months ago and they weren't promised
that they weren't told they were going
to get that that wasn't in their
contract that wasn't
it it was a different product or it
might be the same product that's changed
i am not making it up at crash courses
when i say
this is an offer and this is an offer
for today only
i'm not making it up it legitimately is
an offer for today only but then what
people do is they
video me saying the offer and then they
use it and
you can't take a piece of footage from a
previous time and bring it to you with
this that's just not how it works
imagine buying a car from a car
dealership and then saying to them
hey i just bought this car and paid this
much and i have these features
but here's an advert from three years
ago where you say that that car is worth
this and has these features
and what are they gonna say yeah but
that's an advert from three years ago
when you came in yes it's the same car
yes it's got the same name even but when
you came in what did we tell you were
the features
what did we tell you was the price when
you came in you can't find an advert
from three years ago
and then try and use that for all again
because that's an out of day advert
although it's the same car the model has
changed and in the same way that's why
we make it really
clear at every crash course that we do
we always say
this is the offer today this is what you
get exactly but
this offer is for now only make it
really clear that this is an offer for
now
and when i explained this at the time
quite a lot of my
followers went on mike's channel and
said hey come on you know you didn't
expose him at all what's this and he
wasn't lying about the grant cardone
thing and models changed
and mike's response was look i didn't
know the facts when samuel came on
i hadn't investigated him properly i
just had to take his word for it
i don't know what the facts are that was
mike's defense for why he couldn't
expose me
okay so i thought well who does know the
facts because now i'm kind of like
itching to meet with the biggest skeptic
someone that's really investigated me
and i want to just set this all straight
i want to set the record straight so
i actually offered to meet up with
vanessa warwick from property tribes
because she seemed to be the person with
the biggest knowledge about me despite
never meeting me
she talked about me a lot and she'd
spoken about me
more than anybody else on the internet
and
i said let's meet up and let's have a
chat
vanessa i'd love you to interview me you
can cross-examine me
we can film it and you you're very
interested to get to the bottom of the
truth you're saying look i'm a
truth-seeker
i want to find out if you're genuine i
want to separate the good and the bad
so i'm so i said let's just meet
interview me
live unedited none of that nonsense and
let's just have a conversation and i
thought it'd be a really healthy
conversation
maybe we should challenge me maybe i'd
grow from it i'd learn
we'd disagree we'd agree to disagree
people would be able to make up their
own mind and actually get to the bottom
of
all of this and see both sides and make
up their own mind
however surprise surprise vanessa
warwick did not want to meet with me to
do this now i thought that was really
really strange that she didn't want to
meet me
when she was so interested in getting to
the bottom of the truth and finding
facts and when this kind of went public
what happened was some of my followers
started putting a little bit of pressure
on vanessa to meet with me
and people started investigating the
situation and it turned out that she
didn't just have a problem with
me or my training she actually seemed to
have a problem with
every property trainer out there in fact
vanessa warwick herself says that the
only property trainer that she could
possibly recommend
would be a guy called john and john the
property trainer just so happens to be a
sponsor on her website so the only
property trainer that she can recommend
is somebody who pays her money
all the other property trainers are no
good and people started calling her out
a little bit for this and saying come on
vanessa people started investigating
and finding the facts and i mean geez it
wasn't great for vanessa if i'm
perfectly honest it turned out that
she'd been
a property trainer herself but she kind
of failed because the company that she
worked for inside track got closed down
put into liquidation
and had loads of bad press written about
them in fact there was a one news
article written specifically about
vanessa
where it names her and it says about how
she was hard selling and pressure
selling and promising
and all the things that she was accusing
me of i was looking i was thinking oh my
goodness that's where she's come from
and the fact that she tells says that
you're a failed property property person
you're a failed property person not only
does she fail as a property trainer
but also actually her property business
also has no evidence of any success
either so
it kind of became apparent to people
that she was a failed property trainer
and a failed property investor so now
she's a property journalist
that has a forum writes threads tries to
create controversy and get
views to then get sponsors so she has
letting agencies
mortgage brokers that pay her money
to come on her forum and what she wants
is she wants lots of views on her forum
and guess who's for thread was the most
popular
mine every time she'd put my name in one
of the threads and say bad stuff and
create
controversy people would go on it they'd
check it out vanessa would say
somehow i don't want to meet you just
come on the thread come on the threats i
thought
oh okay so this to her is a business
she didn't make money from training she
didn't make money from property or at
least much not a lot
now her income her income her livelihood
is writing stories and getting people to
pay
to go on her forum all right fair enough
now as people started to call her out on
this
and and basically said that she was a
scammer and she was just doing it to get
money
and she's saying samuel you shouldn't
charge so much for your training courses
i teach people for free go on my forum
instead of it's like yeah but you charge
your sponsors and
to be honest a lot of your teaching in
my opinion is a little bit rubbish
anyway you say
really ludicrous things like rent to
rent a scam and this doesn't work and if
you think everything doesn't work so
much it's probably because it didn't
work for you
so i wouldn't really want to go on the
forum too much anyway and as people
started talking about vanessa there was
websites written about her
there was people going on her own forum
calling her out asking her questions
and she really panicked and she started
blocking them she started taking down
websites
and i know this is the case because
vanessa warwick actually phoned me
up and she said samuel you need to stop
all this
people are saying things and they're
writing things she says they're even
someone
who's been publishing adverts sex
adverts
publishing me as a sex worker i'm like
what what what why are you phoning me
and what are you talking about i said
and we had a conversation i recorded the
conversation by the way because she
absolutely
twisted what happened but this is what
happened i recorded the conversation
she contacted me and said that she was
getting emails saying that she was a
scammer
she was getting emails she was getting
messages people creating forums about
her
calling her out and she said that she
had an inkling
that it was my followers that were doing
it and she was asking me
to try and match up these people's names
to see if they were my students on my
crm system
and then wanted me to have a word with
them and tell them to stop
and i just said vanessa i'm not prepared
to spend my time trying to defend and
help you
i said why don't we just meet up have a
nice
frank conversation and i think it will
probably all stop
i said you've been writing threads about
me for ages why don't you
take down your threads about me and
before you start asking me to help you
this is crazy so we had a conversation
she then said
that someone had posted her as a sex
worker all over the internet
she said she thinks it's to do with my
students and my and i said
i don't know if it's my students or not
but i don't really think i can help you
i did agree to keep my eyes open and if
i saw or heard any of it
to tell people to stop i also posted on
my facebook group
and told people let's just be adults i
also said again
i'm happily to meet with vanessa warwick
i said she said that there's been things
going on her number's been posted on the
internet i said please
if anyone's doing that and you're my
people stop it we are adults so that was
how i handled it
shortly after that i was contacted by
the police
and the police said we want to talk to
you because vanessa is saying that she's
being harassed and she's getting hassled
and i thought okay i don't know why the
police are contacting me
i said i'm happy to help i'll give you
any information i've got
and i went down for a voluntary
interview
at the police station now just for the
record this voluntary interview at the
police station
you know it was like a it wasn't even
like a police station i was at a
community sort of center they made me a
cup of tea
they asked me about my castle vanessa
then
published on her on her property tribe's
thread that there was a crime reference
number
and i was going to the police station
the police were investigating me i'm
like
vanessa come on
you could ring the police now and say i
think there's someone at my house and
the police would give you a crime
reference number because it's a
reference from when you you reported
something it's a crime reference number
so
anyone can have a crime reference number
but the way she painted it there's a
crime reference number the police are
investigating samuel's going to the
station
suddenly it's a story the truth is i
went down for a voluntary interview to
ask how i could help
the police looked into it and the police
even told me no you know there's no real
crime
they haven't really got anything on
thanks for your help what like so
that happened which i thought was
absolutely outrageous
never spoken about this before but it
gets a whole
lot worse vanessa then starts not only
publishing stories on her thread about
me going to the police station and
there's this crime reference number but
she starts
contacting my family she contacts my
pastor of my church and says you
shouldn't associate with samuel leeds
there's been a police matter and a crime
reference
like what are you kidding me
of course she won't meet me to talk
about this but now
trying to make me look like a criminal
all this talk though on property tribes
from vanessa warwick about all this
drama and all this stuff
starts getting loads of views people
start supporting her she says that she's
so
stressed and she's had to go to the
doctors and
and i'm just like i just i just can't
believe that she's trying to pin
something on me
and her mental health and her i'm not
the person that's been
harassing her and and writing about
she's been doing to me now for
years at this point this is what i
really realized that when people say
stuff about me that's not
true or not nice it's not personal
and i grew a bit of a thick skin because
i realized okay vanessa warwick
initially i thought oh she's trying to
help people she's probably a really good
person
maybe she just wants to get to the
bottom of the truth wants to expose the
sharks
good job let's chat let's help each
other but then i realized actually
there's a real strong agenda because
the direct amount of views that she gets
on her forum
actually equals in how much she gets
paid because when she sells to her
sponsors
she says this is how many views we get a
week and this is how much you can pay me
as a result
so she's trying to use my name and
stories and controversy just because i'm
getting a lot of views on my youtube
channel i'm filling events and stuff
she's trying to use to for her to get
paid so it's not personal
and i kind of got used to this and
thought all right fine the people that
really kind of upset me
would be when people would be haters or
say stuff who are my actual students
as i was growing i was getting really
big they were saying but samuel i like
it intimate and why are you teaching all
these people
i mean even paul waters who was a very
successful student i'd taken him to see
robert de niro he'd met up with
robert kiyosaki i'd paid for it taking
him to barcelona
where he'd become very successful doing
a lot of deals made the papers because
of how successful he is he said to me
something you can't be the best training
company and the biggest
you know you need to just be the best
don't jump and i'm like what why
why i see why even students telling me
not to grow and why are they
almost fighting with each other i'd
bring a few winners wednesday students
and then they arguing amongst each other
trying to pull each other down i'm like
guys what are you doing
why are you trying to stop the crash
courses getting bigger oh it loses its
magic when you get more than 500 people
just keep it to a few hundred like it
was back in the day
no that's not my intention my intentions
to go really big
my intention is to help as many people
as i can and in the same way that i've
helped you
become successful and i've invested time
with you and now you're successful
you should be helping other people
you're not saying okay now i've made it
stop samuel slow down and we shouldn't
tell anybody and compete with each other
so some of these students were hating on
me a little bit maybe some of it was
just i don't know there's always going
to be people that like you there's
always going to be people that don't
but the hate from property tribes and
some of these people were coming over
onto property tribe saying yes he's
growing too big
and yeah it wasn't great i didn't like
it but it wasn't too bad
yet and the main thing that made it not
too bad to be honest
was the fact that in my family and in my
life most people that knew me and talked
to me
absolutely were wonderful in fact i've
only ever once had somebody
in real life but she's seen face to face
say to me i don't agree with your
training or i don't only once
all this nonsense all this bad stuff
it's all online and nearly all of it's
on property drives anyway
and the only once that it happened in
real life and it was it was a little bit
awkward because i was actually out
at starbucks with a celebrity and we
were chatting about business and this
person came over to an author and
started talking
acted like he was a friend and stuff was
oh wow sat down
and then slowly started getting a little
bit bitter and said actually samuel i i
don't think you're good at that
and i was thinking this has never
happened before and it turns out i said
what do you do though what's your
occupation what does he do
of course he is a property mentor
all these people have got an issue it
all comes down to money
it's just like they want they're either
trying to compete with me or they don't
want me to teach more people because
they're competing with my students
competing with each other and it comes
down to jealousy competition and greed
nearly all probably 100 of the time i
don't know what the stats are but i
realized that
made it a little bit less personal but
despite all this i
genuinely just wanted to help as many
people as i could and i thought
for every time you get a hater you're
going to have probably helped 10 or 100
people
and i just continued teaching and most
of our students were coming from london
and we're in wolverhampton and they were
traveling down
and people were flying in from all over
the world and often coming from london
so i thought you know what
i want to continue growing i want to
continue helping people and i'm going to
scale and systemize
the training business as well as
continue to grow my property business
and we move to london and of course that
upset a lot of people as well you know
you've changed why are you moving to
london
you know you're a black country boy
remember your roots and i had
all this not just from um normally
people might as they begin to get
successful as they begin to grow they'll
have a few friends or a few family
members saying no don't they're trying
to hold them back
now i've actually got quite even quite a
lot of my students people have become
financially free
i like don't move to london don't keep i
had that and it was painful but i felt
it was the right thing to do for my
business and for my mission so what was
the hardest bit for me
what was the really hard point for me
and i want to share this and i've not
shared this before
but people that are saying things online
on property tribes and generally online
it's growing with might win it and
it tends to be people who have either
never done the training and don't know
me from adam like vanessa warwick and i
don't
care about that or people that have done
the training
and actually loved the training like
diane granville
who've loved it gave me video
testimonials and then now they're
trolling me online
or even like paul waters who did the
training and became
really successful and we became close
friends i spent a lot of time with him
and now he said you've changed stop
growing so big you can't be the biggest
and the best
and now he's actually continued saying
bad things about me online i'm meeting
with him i'm trying to sort it out
and it's like i mean for me the painful
side is is that and if someone went
online and said i went to samuel's
course and it was crap
i'm not offended by that okay that's
feedback no problem but that doesn't
actually very
often happen it what happens is people
go on and they actually have enjoyed it
or they've done well off the back of it
so i'm finding this really confusing i'm
trying to talk to paul waters i'm trying
to talk to people i'm trying to get to
the bottom of
why why are these people that have
actually done really well in property as
a result of my training why are these
people saying about
stuff because that i'm i'm questioning
myself now i'm saying am i going a bit
cold on them
am i training them up and then when they
become successful suddenly going great
you've done it and ignoring them like
how can i change what can i learn from
this i think one of the things i learned
from this is
part of my core value system is if
someone's helped me i have to
honor them i have to thank thank them
for it like as part of my code of honor
and if i've helped someone in property
some of the people that i helped
and then they're becoming successful and
they're doing well but
they suddenly say oh sammy i've seen
some of the height and i want to
distance myself
i i took that really personally and
now i'm kind of used to it and i've
grown a little bit
but that really grated with me and
i've i've learned a lot from that so
right now i've got haters okay i've got
a lot of haters
it's happening i've also got a lot of
success students
and i'm growing and overall it's going
great
um just after the summer 2019 september
beginning of october time
uh there was a group set up about me
called the truth about samuel leeds
and i'm just like again you know
whatever and it was paul waters that
kind of initiated this with a post
which upset me but it this this is just
something i'm gonna have to get used to
right so
i can't answer everybody i can't please
everybody and if you could
please a hundred percent of people a
hundred percent of the time
and you're everybody's cup of tea then
you may as well be a mug
and to be honest at this time my
advisors were more worried
about and i don't mean to sound all
conspiracy now or anything but more
worried
about what the government and
potentially the media might be thinking
because at this point i'm getting a
thousand people a week
at my crash courses so people are flying
from all over the world i've got this
little group about me
vanessa warwick diane granville paul
waters
andrew burgess there's a few of these
guys that are going on and on and on and
trying to find dirt on me but actually i
get a thousand people a week it's going
crazy and my teaching
wealth creation don't follow the status
quo
is anti what the system teaches you
and our wealth creation training company
is blowing up and it's getting huge and
people are saying to me
there's going to be people who don't
like this you know there's i mean do you
really think
that the government are going to have no
opinion at all do you really think the
government just came like oh well
whatever you've got a thousand people a
week and this message is growing but it
doesn't matter
when i'm teaching against a lot of the
status quo against do you think they're
just gonna sit back and say oh
no they're gonna have an opinion and
people are advising me to tone it down
honestly my advice is don't speak about
the help to buy you're gonna
tick people off the wrong people off i'm
like but this is the truth
these are the facts this is no no but
you just have to be careful and don't
talk about this and don't say this
and a lot of my advisors now and my new
business mentors are trying to
turn me into something a bit more
vanilla in my opinion a little bit more
neutral a little bit more but i'm saying
but that's not going to help people
people need to know the truth
and i need to get the message out there
so i'm just continuing with it
regardless of the consequences people
are really trying to find dirt on me at
this time
i mean vanessa forex already had the
police interview me and tried to create
a story out of that
and the the hate group on this facebook
group they're like
um trying to create stories and talking
and then i'm a bit thinking about the
government and it's like
but i'm just doing my thing and i'm
teaching people the bit where i feel
it just went really really bad
was when it was a suicide
and it was one of our students that took
their life
and when all of these individuals these
few people have been trying to take me
down anyway
they tried to suggest that this person
had decided to take his life
even though there was no evidence for
this at all they tried to suggest it was
because
he'd done our training and it was
somehow my fault my company's fault
and i thought to try and suggest that to
fit
your narrative to try and make me look
bad and you
i just felt that was absolutely
absolutely disgraceful
of course i was very upset about the
suicide
because this is this is someone who's
done my training and i was sad about
that
but then i was also almost just
disgusted
at the the these people trying to trying
to
link it i mean
i was out i was outraged at that and
i've done a whole separate video about
that and my response to that and i've
spoken about this separately
now vanessa warwick and andrew burgess
these people they're trying to get this
story
and they're writing stories about it on
their own forums and then there's
they're saying does anyone know and i
can see it people are sending it to me
does anyone know any journalists if we
could get this
if we could get this picked up on on the
newspapers and on the tv
oh you know this could be good in other
words this this if we link this suicide
and we can get this mainstream this
could really really
negatively affect samuel his his
well-being
his his health his business i mean
people were even saying you know what
would happen if samuel kills himself as
a result of all this bad
online stuff and and then the comments
were just disgusting and people were
almost saying oh well what would it
matter he doesn't care about us and you
know or maybe next we could do it too
and they're naming other property
trainers and i'm
i'm horrified by this and my wife's
getting
messages i'm getting death threats
[Music]
i felt like literally at that
that season it was almost like if if
someone had stabbed me
that everyone would have cheered like
that's how i felt completely
ostracized i decided i need some advice
on how to answer this because
i i've got a lot that i want to say and
i've got a lot that i want to do
to just to just put the facts out there
to to i've got a lot of ideas but
this is such a a sensitive
thing and so so such a sad and i'm
emotional and i'm upset
and i'm also angry so i thought i needed
some advice so i got a
uh pr company and said look what am i
going to do and they said we'll deal
with it you just say nothing
um you know best to just let's just and
basically their strategy was just to say
nothing
and i didn't everything in my gut didn't
like this but they were the experts and
that was that
the media pick up the story and he went
he goes on loads of newspapers and
even the bbc inside out show do it do it
do a little
show on it now of course the newspapers
don't say that
that this person killed themself and it
was linked to me on my training of
course they didn't say the fact that
they actually said it's not linked
but the suggestive language and the talk
what it does is it just makes
this little group of of haters
absolutely
right now we can go now we can go really
dirty now it's all messaged this person
let's let's
every time samuel does business with
anybody let's tell them
that one of his students killed himself
and let's and they just get really
really nasty start talking about my
physical appearance messaging my wife
messaging my family publishing my
whereabouts online
saying look he was at stage but this
time maybe he'll be the same place
tomorrow
and it's like this is really really not
cool
i'm getting journalists at my events and
my my crash courses
trying to catch me out and it's all been
arranged by these same
few people vanessa warwick and the few
people on this
on this truth about samuel leeds group
and i don't
believe that they were going after me i
don't think it was personal
the whole industry the whole training
wealth creation industry
was really in the spotlight and was
being scrutinized and maybe that's not a
bad thing
and i'm the biggest in the uk
i've got a thousand people a week coming
to my events and also i'm not the
typical kind of
you know professional spoken i'm quite
loud and i'm open to do interviews and
things
so of course they're probably really
going to go after me
as as the the scope go as i felt at the
time for the industry
and they're coming after me really
really hard and
what's happening is the stories are not
being written by the journalists the
stories are being written and
investigated by vanessa warwick and
andrew burgess and then passed to the
media and the media aren't
coming to me and saying look can we have
a chat with an interview they're trying
to
catch me out they're coming with
with a with a story oh this sounds like
a good story and then they're trying to
get evidence to back up that story and
i'll give you some examples like the
whole thing with joe lysa joe license
said i've been trying to hunt samuel
he's down for three months
we have been tracking this guy for
months and
this is our one chance to get him and so
i'm super nervous
but super thrilled that he's that's not
true i was
every week i was doing a crash course
and publishing where i was
he never messaged me what he really
meant is i've been trying to catch him
out for three months
rumpus media who were the ones that put
the show to
actually together and edited it they
actually tried to set me
up they didn't say samuel can we have a
chat about your business because we've
got some concerns we've heard from this
group i didn't say that what they did is
they tried to set me up by saying samuel
we want you to be the star of this show
on channel five you'd be perfect for it
can you come down and can we do some
interviews with you and and they were
trying to set me up
they tried to boost me up and then to
but but luckily
i got good people around me and actually
people might just miss judging oh samuel
with particulars ego me but actually i
didn't want to be on tv right
i was like i'm good i'm i'm fine i've
got a good team around me
and rumpus media were trying to set me
up and then joe lysak
ambushes me a crash course suddenly
pulls loads of cameras in my face one of
my crash course
and tries to present me with an award
and humiliate me
and i was course just like look i'm
happy to have a chat with you let's meet
up and have an appointment and i've
spoken
in depth about the joe license show in
fact the bbc
all these media people that write these
stories
i always say let's do an interview
afterwards and say can we talk about
what happened can we and they always
just run
like flies and if you want to know more
about those shows
i've done a whole playlist where i've
done a response to the bbc i've been a
response to joe lysa i've done a sponsor
to the
shaft dragon i've done a response to
i've done the responses and i put them
in a whole playlist but this video is
more about
where it came from and my story
beginning to end now at this time i'm a
member
of professional training associations
with other trainers where we help each
other out and
and all these other training companies
they're getting really really worried
okay i'll give you some inside
information right now
all my friends and contacts that also
have training companies
they're pulling their hair out saying to
me samuel how can we stop germans coming
to our events
i'm like i'm probably not the guys to
ask right now i'm probably a bit naive
to it myself
and there's other training companies
that get really annoyed with me
and they're saying you're bringing media
attention to this whole industry i'm
like okay well
sars stops for being the biggest i think
it would have happened anyway
and i remember sat down with a whole
bunch of trainers and they're saying
like whoa what's going on samuel what's
all this media stuff and i said well
look
i'm being scrutinized by the media they
haven't really got anything on me apart
from suggestions and
half truths and but actually you know
what my business is pretty
airtight my standards are high
our training our follow-up our contracts
our legalities it's
tight i'm actually for regulation
and i'm i'm thinking if i was some of
these guys i might be a little bit
worried not they're bad people but there
are some cowboys in the industry and
there are also people in the industry
that are doing an okay job i'm doing a
good job i've got winners wednesdays
coming on becoming successful
every single week 90 of my actual
students are
really happy which is outrageously high
i'm doing
independent feedback surveys
independently at all of my events
i'm actually doing a good job so they're
scrutinizing me
some of you should be worried not me
they couldn't argue with me
like yeah i'm the real deal not as a
property investor only but also as a
trainer
but a lot of them like we don't want to
associate though i know we have this
youtube interview booked with you in
that bottle we want to distance
ourselves
and i'm thinking okay interesting i mean
so many people and it's
to be honest it was out of fear my
tenants i had tenants moving out of some
of how
some of my houses because this little
small campaign these people
would find out they'd watch my videos
and find out addresses and they'd
contact the tenants and start saying do
you know that you're living in one of
the houses of samuel leeds who's this
and it's like i'm getting interrogated
from every which side when i do a
financial freedom challenge they're
harassing everybody that i've done
business with even people
i moved into glenn's house and spent a
week with him helped him get loads of
property deals he made 50
000 pounds and more within a short space
of time deal sourcing
he'd obviously been involved in a
documentary that we did together that
had over half a million views
suddenly he puts out a statement which
is a negative statement about me i'm
like
glenn the dude that that's really
weird now this time i've grown thicker
skin but that's the kind of betrayal i'm
talking about i'm like
why would glennon said something
negative about me that doesn't make any
sense
i felt like glenn why did you say that
what's happening can i help
turns out he's been threatened by who
by people within this little hate group
and all of my students and all of my
people and my
business associates are being harassed
by these individuals i have a video that
goes on lad bye but i'm like oh cool lad
bible picked up a video i didn't pay for
it they just pictures up ran with it
then the video gets taken down i'm like
that bubble what happened
okay same story they were harassed
and on the group people are saying let's
all comment on the video
and say that samuel leeds is a murderer
and ladby but i'm just going to be like
whoa i don't want to be involved they'll
just take down the video
and when the video got taken down guess
what these these people did on the hate
group they
uh and andrew burgess said great we're
doing a good job
because blood bible removes samuel's
video like in what world is this
reasonable
yeah these people don't give me a reason
haven't actually got anything to say to
me
but are trying to sabotage every single
relationship even lord sugar
did you ever wonder why did lord sugar
give samuel business advice sit with him
and then do a video saying i never met
someone oh i didn't give him business
advice like why would lord sugar have
done that
and it's really obvious when you
understand the backstory probably
because
lord sugar was hounded on twitter and
his
agency was hounded by vanessa warwick
and said don't associate don't associate
all these people into the group
encouraging people like puppets you see
this these these
vanessa warwick and property tribes and
the admins of this facebook group
have got a personal vendetta and a
commercial gain
and then tell this story and try and
make everybody else like a puppet
let's all tweet lord sugar and
everyone's just oh tweeting lord sugar
getting in touch with the agent and then
lord sugar does a video there's no doubt
and he's just and you could tell on the
videos reading a script
which is pr agent company said you
really need to read this because we need
to
disassociate you from samuel lee's
because you're getting hounded
meanwhile people are saying to me
something you need to show receipts for
every mentor that you've had i'm
thinking
why so you can harass them and get them
to disassociate from me
samuel if you're the real deal give us
all your addresses for your properties
why so you can write to all my tenants
no thanks
always not the real deal because he
doesn't show receipts for his
mentors damned if you do damned if you
don't
like it's ridiculous and the thing i'm
having to get used to
is when people are saying samuel we
wouldn't be here without you you've
mentored us you've trained us
but you know what all this hate that
you're getting we need to distance
ourselves from you i'm like
that is to me it's so hurtful
but i understand but it was really
painful
even simon zushi who i've credited for
10 years because i have this sense of
recognition when someone's telling me
i've got a credit that no matter what
i'm always crediting simon zushei and
simon zushi was pulled up on an
interview and someone said simon it says
this on samuel's website little quote
from simon
did you really say that about samuel
even simon was like no i never said that
i'm like thinking simon you did say that
i rang simon up i'm like sorry man why
did you say you've never said that
i've got a video of you actually saying
it about me like what's going on
there is the testimonial that says from
simon sushi
i was so impressed with the value that
samuel brings when teaching property
investing
thank you simon sushi uh well respected
property investor well that's true
so simon did you say those words yes or
no so no
i didn't give that test something my
name is sometimes used in vain
i was really impressed with the amazing
value and content
samuel gave across the bible so really
great speaker listen to what he's got
i love simon to bits okay i don't know
whether simon just forgot
or whatever but what i do know is
everybody was being pressured like crazy
to distance themselves from me to try
and isolate and ostracize me with no
good reason apart from hearsay rumors
that were not true
i'm now thinking i need to not get
bitter
i need to get better i need to become
the best
now not just the best not just the
biggest but the fairest
the most self-regulated the highest
standards
i mean i'm writing down my regulation
standards how we're going to
self-regulate which is coming in another
video
and i'm thinking this is hard no one
will be able to compete with this
i see that there's a little bureau a
property investors bureau which are
self-regulating property trainers i'm
like
awesome maybe they'll be able to help me
out i can show them my plans
so i messaged the bureau i'm like hey
could you help me i'd love to talk i'd
love to i'm really for the idea of
regulation
guess what they don't even respond to me
they just like bluff me off we'll get
back to us get back to us get back to us
and i'm thinking even the bureau then
they're not they're about pr
they don't want to associate with me
they're not trying to help training
companies
they're just trying to create a good
image for their own pr
and it just came clear to me and this
bureau
that was is being set up the guy that
they were putting in charge of the
redress
is a guy who's trolling me
isn't serious and he said look look at
samuel what a disreputable character
who who pretending that he's associated
with lord sugar and had business advice
from lord sugar i'm thinking i did have
business advice from lord sugar you want
you guys why not just speak to me why
post things and publish things and say
things without just coming to me
let's talk no one wants to talk to me
they just want to say things
involved in this smear campaign
distancing themselves
so in the end i just thought you know
what i've had enough and i started
addressing it and i put a video out
about lord sugar and i produced evidence
that i had met lord sugar and had advice
from lord
sugar i was responding to bbc i
responded to channel four i responded to
the dragon i responded to everybody bang
bang bang bang bang and then guess what
happened
everybody certainly wants to be my
friend again even
even people that are part of the
property investors bureau okay had this
guy message me oh samuel you know what
we said was wrong and
um you know let's talk and let's be
friends and let's do publicly said bad
things about me
now wants to say good things in private
and i'm just thinking
you know what after all this hassle i
i've had to spend all this time
and energy putting together all these
responses with evidence
setting the record straight in order
people to go oh okay i'm sorry i'm going
wrong
now everyone wants to be my friend
people saying let's do a youtube collab
i mean honestly i can see why most rich
people
do hide because most rich people hide as
soon as people get really wealthy they
think i'm gonna hide away i'm gonna keep
it to myself i keep the knowledge to
myself
you know what i'm not gonna do that i'm
not gonna hide i'm gonna continue
teaching i'm gonna continue
training come what may because that is
my mission
and through all of this i've been
putting a youtube video out every single
day
throughout all of this i've been having
a winner's wednesday who's become
successful through property on my
channel every single week and all these
little haters now
vanessa warwick andrew burgess they
won't speak to me now
i've put the facts out there now
suddenly they're like they don't want to
talk to me they're still talking a lot
they're still saying lots and lots of
things
i've rang them up i rang up vanessa
warwick
yesterday and what did she say
as soon as she heard my voice she's like
hello i'm like
hey vanessa samuel leads love to have a
have a little chat i don't want to talk
to you
puts the phone down then she messages me
immediately afterwards and says if you
call me again
i'm going to report you to the police
for harassment i'm just like
i mean that's the first time i've ever
called her
and she's like bang i'm going to get you
done for harassment that'll be another
crime reference number another story for
her
andrew burgess i phoned up andrew
burgess i said to him
andrew look i just want to chat to you
and see what the grievance is i want i
really want to understand
and he couldn't give me one grievance
he's like oh i don't know i don't want
to i'm like crack what's up i think are
you okay like what's the issue
what can i do differently what's what's
what is your complaint because
you've been doing all these suggestions
and saying all these stories and
trying to gather all these people up
saying say these bad things about samuel
it's all these bad reviews it's all but
what action is your grievance i was very
calm on the phone
the phone call was recorded and he's
like oh i don't know i i i don't want to
speak to you i said because i've got
nothing to say i said you say you've got
nothing to say but you clearly
have so because you've been you've
posted over a thousand times about me so
what's up what's your issue i don't know
i don't want to die
he has nothing to say and he starts
going why did you call me
there's lots of other people you know
there's lots of other people it's not
just me i'm not okay that's fine but
you're
you're one are you you're probably the
main one so what's up
and then in the end he can't speak he
can't give one reason
as to why he's been doing it no reason
and then when the phone call finishes he
messages me saying
you know please don't please don't um
publish this
please don't publish this so he comes to
he comes to my crash courses
and films and edits and does i didn't
even want to try and spin anything i was
like let's just talk i want to have a
conversation run away
doesn't want to talk to me cowards
typical keyboard warriors
to be fair i rang a lot of these haters
i think a lot of them
not one of them could give me a reason
as to why they're hanging
not one of them wanted to speak to me
none yet online they're so loud and it
just
just shows what kind of people these are
the only person that was prepared to
have an on the record
conversation with me recorded fair
enough was
paul waters and we had a very frank
conversation for
oh well over an hour and he gave me all
these things but what about people
saying this and what about people saying
that what about this
i said okay what was your experience and
even paul said you know what
my experience was really really good and
i made my money back and more i said
why are you saying bad things about me
why are you saying things about my
appearance online
why are you publishing my phone number
online and trying to cause me problems
what's the issue when most of my
customers are happy and
what what am i doing wrong man well he
said well
lots of people are saying bad things
though aren't they and there's no smoke
without fire why is everyone saying bad
stuff i said you tell me you're one of
the ones you're one of the main ones
again you've posted over a thousand
times why
well i'm i have freedom of speech though
i said you do i'm just interested why
what's the issue
every single point he said i answered
and that phone call was recorded
and he gave me permission to publish
that phone call which is great
so i'll publish that um maybe there's a
couple days or something and you can
listen to the whole conversation if you
want it's a really
helpful conversation if you've got
questions for me if you're thinking like
but what about what that person said
what about that
honestly paul waters hit every single
one of me and i answered with facts and
evidence
so before you stop making judgments or
just listen to that conversation now the
conversation me and paul had it was a
very civil conversation and i thank paul
for being
having the courtesy and the decency to
be the only person that would speak to
me
and if you want to listen to the call
because he had a lot to ask me
ask me loads every question under the
sun what about this what about this one
of those
but but i answered them very nicely
it ended very civilly and if you want to
listen to that conversation again before
you stop before you start thinking if
you might have other rumors what about
this one
i put all of them to bed so i'll be
publishing that phone call as well very
very soon
and no doubt some of these small
individuals that make out those loads by
the way they're like but this group has
got 3 000 members yeah but to be honest
you just add people
i've had people that have been friends
of mine that have been like oh my gosh
you're not saying i just found out i was
in that group because i was added
it's like there's actually only a few
but they speak
very very loudly no doubt vanessa will
even respond to this video she'll be
like
putting together some really strange
twisted version because she'll want me
to go on that thread
vanessa you want to put this to bed you
want to get your side of the story
across let's meet up i'm happy to come
on your channel you're about to go on
mine i think that's pretty reasonable i
think
it's so easy to hide behind a keyboard
it's so easy
to be all big but then these people they
won't meet me i try and call vanessa and
she's just i don't want to talk
but as a journalist which is basically
what you are because you write stories
and that's how you get paid
as a journalist how can you publish
stories without going to the source or
out wanting to meet the sauce
doesn't make any sense so if you see
vanessa saying all kinds of things
just say one simple thing why won't you
meet samuel
for a chat because she won't in all
honesty though
i'm really glad this has happened
because it's forced me to get
better i've learned a lot
and i've also learned how to spot who's
genuine and who's not and who your true
friends are
so i'm going to be releasing another
video soon with actually
on a much more positive note about all
the good
that's come from this all the things
that i've learned and how i've improved
as a person as a businessman
and also how i can differentiate myself
and have and do
as a training company so i'm going to be
publishing that soon also i just want to
say a
massive thank you to those people that
never doubted me to those people that
just said you know what
even though i might not have met him or
i have met him i know samuel i can see
his heart
didn't listen to the rumors you know
what respect thank you for not doubting
i
appreciate you so so much no doubt
there'll be more rumors there'll be more
stories and i can't respond to
everything but if you
see a story or a room i just think would
this person
say this to samuel's face and what is
this person's agenda
how are they going to benefit
financially is it jealousy is it greed
is it competition
just look at the facts make up your own
mind thank you for watching i know it's
been a really long video
if you enjoyed it smash the like button
if you didn't smash the dislike button
drop a comment let me know your thoughts
and don't forget to subscribe because
there's going to be some
epic videos as we move on from this
nonsense and i can go back
to teaching my success students about
how to become financially free